11 soldados rusos han muerto y 15 han
resultado heridos después de que dos
personas abriesen Fuego contra un grupo
de voluntarios que se preparaban para
marchar al frente a luchar contra
Ucrania ha ocurrido en la región rusa de
velogros que limita precisamente con
Ucrania al parecer en un campo de tiro
mientras se estaban llevando a cabo
pruebas precisamente para entrenar a los
soldados para disparar las dos personas
que han abierto fuego han sido abatidas
prácticamente a continuación no se sabe
a estas horas sus nacionalidad pero si
se ha dicho que son ciudadanos de una ex
República soviética están siendo unos
días agitados en bergoroth hoy mismo
también ha sido atacado un depósito de
combustible en esa región limítrofes
repetimos con Ucrania parece que ha sido
un ataque ucraniano Aunque a estas horas
kiev no ha reivindicado ninguna de las
dos acciones